there's this there's this uh interesting
overlap between digital marketing
and entertainment and the resistance the
anti-trump democrat types and the
wokeness
and so that's why you see every major
brand change their logo to a rainbow in
june
because they're like this is what people
like but most
people probably just shrug and say i
don't know whatever you know what i mean
like that's cool i guess
it's not like they're actually going to
make more money by doing this
so it's interesting that these companies
that tow that woke line
think it's the right path forward it's
not going to make a money
and i have a story for you check this
out this is from business insider dollar
shave club
has laid off all of its staff at men's
lifestyle site
mel source says and is looking for a
rescue buyer
now on the surface this doesn't sound
like a get go broke story
but i assure you it is they say dollar
shave club is laying off staff
the staff of mel magazine it's men's
lifestyle and culture website
a person with direct knowledge of the
matter said mel staffers were informed
of the layoffs on wednesday
the publication is seeking a buyer and
many and many
i'm sorry and may face shutting down if
it doesn't find one it was unclear how
many people were affected
mel's masthead lists about 20 people
plus 16 contributors they say
after six years of successful
partnership and transforming the men's
health and media spaces for the better
you see that mel and dollar shave club's
financial relationship will come to an
end in 60 days
editor-in-chief josh skollmeyer said in
a statement he added
mel will stop publishing effective
wednesday and the complete focus will
now be on finding the right new owner
this has always been a part of the plan
for our brand-backed partnership
and we're incredibly proud of what we've
built together you got you got to take a
look at this one very important point
they say transforming the men's health
and media spaces for the better what do
you think that means
transforming it for the better it means
making it
less male yes uh getting well look at
this
go to mel magazine.com and the the
headline story do i have to no the
pressure to act like a man
starts in preschool boys as young as
three
are more than happy to police the toy
box and make sure that no little dude
walks away with a barbie
i don't care what does this have to do
with men show me an article where it's
like eating eating steak and fish will
make your muscles bigger or something
stereotypically dude-like i guess that's
the thing give me
three-year-olds on testosterone
replacement therapy
and then i'll agree with you then they
have uh they have this one down here
there's finally a name for trump's
murderous masculinity
well who are they marketing to women
frail
low-t liberal men who can't grow beards
first of all
to say that trump is a vision of
masculinity is just incredibly
misleading
tiny hands possibly fake hair
tanning lotion on the face he's just
like
an out-of-shape master's level
bodybuilder at best
like coming in at 60 thinking he looks
good in the mirror and then he steps out
on stage
against real bodybuilders he's like
trump's thing
a lot of things but what conservative or
trump supporters coming out preaching
about trump's masculinity yeah
i've never like not once no no no like
i've heard talk about
you know working-class populism
protecting the worker
borders national security but i've not
seen that group of like staunch
wearing guys being like trump is our
vision of masculinity there's like
pictures of him artwork where he looks
ripped i have seen those with the hawk
behind him
i love it when ben garrison draws trump
because he makes them
yeah you know super ripped and like
strong but i think they all kind of get
the joke of it trump is an
old he's an old man and he's very out of
shape yeah and i'll tell you this
i'd be willing to bet that compared to
your average person in this country
donald trump
how can i phrase this properly it is
extremely unlikable
likely that donald trump has ever had to
walk a mile um
i mean look he's been he was born into
wealth he he's rich
i'm sure he's walked you know he golfs
right so i'm sure that he's walked
periods
he rides most of the time but he well
now as an old guy but i'm sure
i'm sure you know at some point he he
did walk a mile i'm not saying he never
did that that would be ridiculous
he doesn't have to right and so whereas
a normal person might be like i gotta go
to the store and i gotta walk and carry
a cart with me
trump walks outside there's a car
waiting for him it's probably always
been that way yeah so he's not a vision
of masculinity
i will say this he's
what's the right word for trump i want i
don't want to say like he's a tough guy
pink no no like like aggressive
he's aggressive and arrogant mentally
let's say he's masculine
sure maybe mentally that's what they're
trying to say
but i don't i don't even i don't even
know if i agree with that
i'd say he was i guess i guess if you
say aggressive behavior and arrogance i
mean i think to be a success in business
you have to have
a i don't know if it had see to
determine a masculine mentality is wrong
it's just
uh the idea of grift the idea of
innovation the idea of cutting deals
those are traditionally associated with
male values but they're not you can see
by the success
that uh female business owners have it's
something that can be
emulated so success in business can be
emulated so
just to you know bring it back to the
core issue i guess
there are certain things that men
stereotypically like
and i suppose the argument from these
these brands is that we know we
transformed it for the better
because men shouldn't be masculine it's
toxic or whatever that i guess it's
their attitude they didn't transform it
for the better nobody was reading their
magazine and they're they're losing
their principle sponsor that funded them
because nobody wants to read this stuff
look i don't read men's health
you know and there's a there's a bunch
of channels there was one we did a
segment on um
i can't remember what we're talking
about we're talking about men not
getting oh no we're talking about the
try guys
you know the try guys no so this was a
group of dudes at buzzfeed
and they got their testosterone levels
checked and their testosterone levels
were lower than that of an 85 year old
man
okay now that's sad i'm like i'm not
trying to wreck on these guys i'm like
dude
if you if you go to the doctor and you
get your t levels checked and they're
like yo you're 25 and your testosterone
is lower than that of an 85 year old man
you might have a serious problem yeah i
don't know maybe cancer or something
there might be some serious
hormonal imbalance prostate possibly and
and so everyone's making fun of him like
nah that's a medical issue dude it's not
a joke i can't believe they published
this story but
we had this one guy he's got a youtube
channel it's called i think it's called
more plates more dates
yeah seems like a cool dude he was like
actually adding the conversation
he he runs the video and he's like
there's some good points they made i
thought it was i thought it was great
some criticism some constructive
criticism
and but a lot of the comments were
ragging on us you know they're like oh
these guys don't exercise don't work out
or whatever and it's like i have two
skateparks in my house i go to skate
like almost every single day
i should lift i suppose but i i look at
this these conversations and i wonder
i think that the split here is there are
these people that believe
in constructivism and then there's
essentialism and the constructivists are
like
we can make a men's magazine telling men
that they should play with barbie
and they'll want to read it right and
then there's masculine dudes
who lift and are super ripped talking
about how great they are
you know and making fun of us or
whatever because there are things that i
think guys tend to be into
i think the issue is look there's some
social construction like constructivism
sure but i think dudes have testosterone
i think they have more fast twitch
muscles they have more bone density more
collagen
and there's a reason and guys are
probably going to be predisposed to
certain activities
when you make a magazine built against
all of that
don't be surprised when you collapse
they're trying to go
against nature and be like here's what
you should be
and you're saying naturally a man is not
supposed to be that
i don't you know look it's hard to say
naturally
you know um but that's kind of the gist
it's more like
a tendency right you know men have a
tendency in a certain direction towards
certain activities like the the
guys have high testosterone which means
they're going to build muscle mass
faster
prenatal testosterone results in more
fast switch muscle development which
means they have more burst energy
can sprint can jump can run faster you
can see this all in scientific data
so why would you make a magazine
critical of all of those things
that are physically you know ingrained
in men
people are trying to jump on this thing
where they think it's the right thing to
do and they think it's going to succeed
but your old catchphrase get woke go
broke
is so applicable in so many forms i
haven't seen any
okay successful comedian patton oswald
he's woke but he wasn't always no
he was edgy for years and then now
i mean what's he done lately he's he's
still working it's around i think he's
like you know he he's
a step in the hollywood cog
he works he's there i don't know if
you know a lot of comics are fans of his
and
then there's you know because he's
successful yeah he's also got these
horrible rumors surrounding him
obviously
but it's like i think that happens with
anybody that gets any modicum of success
there's nothing inherently wrong with
masculinity
but i think we're being fed that there
is you're a masculine
guy i think i think there's tremendous
positivity in masculinity i think
masculinity is a tremendous and amazing
thing
and i'll tell you there's one thing that
proves it
the demand and the desire from feminists
to make women more masculine
that's how so they'll well they they
want so if you look at
traditional gender roles between what is
masculine what is feminine
the men were the hunters the gatherers
the the athletes the soldiers
feminists want women in combat they want
women as ceos they want women in the
military-industrial complex
they want women's sports to get more
prominence you got megan rabino saying
we fill stadiums we deserve this money
they want more prominence for female
athletes doing physical activities which
are not traditionally feminine roles
you can argue that gender roles were
wrong sure
that's that's fine making that argument
if you look at
the traditional gender roles you can
argue they're wrong i'm gonna break them
down
and so that means the things you are
encouraging of women are traditionally
masculine
you think those things shouldn't be just
traditionally masculine but you are not
advocating for men to be more feminine
or i should say for the most part
there's where's the big you know
billboard announcement or like magazine
cover story about the ceo who quit to
like raise his kids
there are stories like this for sure but
i mean like
we constantly hear about the new female
ceos we constantly hear about women's
sports and women right
we keep hearing that women need to enter
the world that was traditionally
masculine
that was traditionally a male gender
role and they said it shouldn't be that
way
okay fine argument make the argument
we'll talk about it where is the equal
and opposite reaction saying
men shouldn't be in the workplace men
should be at the home with the kids
that's something that men should do
because think about it this way
no one is saying men should leave the
ceo position
men shouldn't be in the workplace men
should
like where where's the magazine that
says men belong in the home with the
kids
you know men should be doing this when
they talk about women and the role of
women and wives and and girlfriends and
things like this
they say women should be ceos
they say men can be homemakers but
they're not saying they should be
homemakers
right so whatever it is that men have
traditionally done things associated
with masculinity
physical activity combat being the ceo
they want women to do
and they are at the same time not giving
the same amount of energy
to the traditionally feminine roles of
nurturing like you got to you you got to
think about this too like
when you think about what femininity is
i'm not i'm not going to pretend to be
an anthropologist or sociologist but
i'll say
men my view of like man it's like a guy
running into a burning building to carry
out the kids and save their lives
men go and and hunt the you know the
wild boar or whatever to bring food back
for the tribe
they get the job and they go out and
they go on dangerous missions and there
is that uh
i guess there are many people who refer
to it as male expendability
and this is because of you know women
have children and you only need one man
you know to reproduce but you have many
women then when you look at traditional
femininity what do they do
they create people they literally
gestate them birth them and then raise
them and still them with values now
fathers do this as well
but the mothers are the builders of of
people in society and
and cultures that's what feminism idiot
feminine femininity is and it's
extremely important
and i think it's fair to say when you
see many traditional uh
you know commentators will say the
mother's role is in many ways more
important
because you need that nurturing role to
be there to protect and grow
people that's being left behind and
ignored
i wonder you know is it an issue of
encouraging people not to have kids and
families because of overpopulation
or why it is or why it emerged i
honestly don't know but there is a
tendency right now
to disregard the the traditional
feminine role in society while promoting
the traditional masculine role
that says to me that society greatly
favors masculinity over femininity and i
disagree with that
right i i think part of becoming
masculine
and embracing that is that when you get
to a high enough
level of that you achieve this level of
okay i'm
confident enough with where i am as a
man as a provider
as uh you know somebody that supports a
family
that then okay now i can let this these
traditional aspects of femininity into
my life where i can help take care of my
kid and i can do all this stuff
so i think that it's an evolving too
people don't want
equal rights nobody wants equal rights
people want
extraordinary rights i i think that's
what the attempt is when
when i watch uh you know when you
see some experts of of blm or some
up spirits of feminism it's like okay
this is not about achieving
equality it's about achieving a higher
up status
that's what i see when i look at it from
the outside absolutely
it's it's it's power yeah and i think
there's a lot of people especially the
woke people who have found a path to
power lies in victimhood
and that's hence you see the oppression
olympics
and then you see just ridiculous
businesses
and attempts to make money off
controversy
and uh make tv shows that are overly
woke and it's just awful
victimhood is a currency for them for
for comics in the business we had a
woman that you know
our fans made a joke about and then
she's like ah these are rape threats uh
they're coming to my house to it no one
ever did any of those things someone
made an off-color
joke and her victimhood helped propel
her
to the next level i mean she used to
have 5 000 followers she's got 60 000
now
then she'll make a a joke about i hope
trump dies or something and then
then people go after her and she'll be
like oh but look what happened some guy
called me uh d-y-k-a am i allowed to say
that no not on youtube but
i i'm i find that i spelled it really
curious like
i constantly hear from these journalists
that they get emails like these female
journalists get emails from guys who
call them awful names and say you're
awful fake news
and they use all the slurs in the book
and i'm like i wonder who writes those
emails
you know what i mean like you get this
female journalist you work the new york
times
and then she posts a screenshot saying
here's an email i just received
and i'm like dude i get emails too i
just don't post them yeah i get death
threats
i don't post them they but they know
because currency and they're on in their
tribe
because then we're hypocrites if we post
them we go hey look someone just
threatened it literally i
have a screenshot of someone saying it
would be really funny
if uh some of your loved ones died
and i know who the guy is i know he's a
real guy
but i don't post it because if i post it
then people are like well you should
take it you're a big bad comedian you
should be able to take the death threats
but the other side
is not supposed to it's it's yes and i
also think
so where's the equality is anybody on
the side of freedom
maturity going to be like i'm so sorry
for you oh let me let me
donate to your gofundme because someone
said mean words they're going to be like
why are you posting this
yeah like you know we we know you're
strong enough to be resilient towards
the stuff
and you know we don't care yeah on their
side
the way it works is there are there's a
there are large swathes of people
who don't know and don't pay attention
right so here's a really good example we
had jody
shaw on the show the other day right are
you familiar with her story she works at
she worked at smith college
and she quit and filed a complaint over
hostile work environment because they
kept
you know criticizing her for being white
and telling her to talk about her race
and
negatively impacting her job based on
race and she was saying how she didn't
complain about it at first because she
just thought it was normal and why
people don't complain about this stuff
and then eventually she realized it was
really eating away inside
and that she couldn't stand being
attacked based on race and she did
something about it
so what happens is that that that first
part of the story she told where she
said you you just supposed to accept it
you're not supposed to complain about
this
this is what these these journalists and
these these cancel culture people make
make their the social currency off of
regular people who aren't paying
attention to politics and don't know
they hear a story about a journalist
who's getting death threats from trump
supporters
poisons the well for trump supporters
then there'll be a trump supporter
saying like
you know a reasonable rational guy with
a maga hat and they'll be like it's you
you're the people doing that
and it's because these individuals have
no idea what's going on don't read the
news
don't follow the culture and then
they're fed these stories
they just believe them the weapons work
now for you
you don't have access to the new york
times platform so you posting that
screenshot won't do anything for you
it does everything for them because they
have access to legacy media in
these powerful institutions which is why
i tweeted earlier i think i found a
solution
to uh help unify the left and the right
okay i think we can get the bernie
sanders
supporters and the socialists and the
trump supporters and conservatives
together
in the same room if we just propose one
policy change
taxing hollywood millionaires and
billionaires and
legacy media millionaires and
billionaires at 90 of their income
because then the leftists are like tax
the rich i'll take it and the
conservatives are like oh the hollywood
liberal types and the media
do it that's a good idea i've always
advocated for tax the poor
i think that taxing the poor is a great
way to get home
people to hustle you know pick yourself
up by your bootstraps
tax the poor and it's a great hoodie too
well that you know bloomberg actually
proposed that did he
michael bloomberg uh said poor people
spend money on stupid things i'm
paraphrasing and he was like so you tax
them and then we can
better spend that money for them
i think that is insane okay
first and foremost the first part i
think is true
for everybody people buy dumb stuff yeah
like dude
i look at like these yachts from these
rich guys and i'm like why you have that
come on elon musk is doing it right what
did he do he bought a spaceship
yeah right on brother he's building a
spaceship and electric cars
the yacht of the skies they call it but
there's a functional purpose to
scientific research towards going to
mars and
it's helping all of humanity this
research he's doing then you look at
some of these other billionaires and
millionaires and they're like i have a
large boat
it's like okay i guess it's nice and
comfortable
but that's buying something dumb right
and then you look at these people who in
the lottery and they buy like golden
statues of themselves
yeah it's like why would you do that i
guess you got to put your money
somewhere
but a giant these are lottery winners
you see the people that
go in yeah tickets you're like
oh these people win the lottery well in
recent history people who in the lottery
have learned
and started hiring wealth management you
know wealth managers and things like
that
the point is it doesn't matter if you're
rich or poor people buy dumb things yeah
so bloomberg has a good point in that
poor people are buying dumb things
but bro you want to be the despot to
tell people they can't buy
a sandwich they want to eat that's nuts
that's and he did that he wanted to ban
large sodas
yeah his idea was remember that we take
all their money away and then we give
them what we know they need
yeah sure something like food stamps ebt
cards that type of thing
yeah is that
if people knew that they were being say
you you're at a minimum wage job you're
making
let's say you're making 14 an hour in a
grocery store not minimum wage
uh and then you know maybe you're making
26 grand a year but you're in this
lowest tax bracket and 50
of that goes to taxes but if you get to
35
000 they're gonna drop that rate to ten
percent
only fifteen percent but it only works
for the money above so like
the first thirteen thousand dollars i
think is tax-free yeah they're i think
you still gotta pay like medicare tax or
whatever
then from 13 to 35 years you're it's
like 12 percent
then from 35 to like 100 and something i
think or to like 80
it's like 21 then it goes up to 30. so
you're not actually
losing money by making more money right
a lot of people think that but
what i i do think for uh
what's the saying it's like only 47
percent of americans actually pay income
tax
yeah and that's because a lot of people
are the poverty level where they don't
actually
have to pay anything or they get a
refund back thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time